hey everyone and welcome back to the
Channel first off thank you all for
15,000 subscribers it is a true honor to
keep making these videos and interacting
with all of you makes my day so much
better to have all of you in my life
more importantly I am pretty tired so
I'm going to try and get this video done
with pretty quickly and then we can
celebrate those 15K at some other point
uh I've obviously got to see the gym
wife early in the morning tomorrow and
by Jim wife I mean we've exchanged zero
words ever so without further Ado let's
go ahead and talk about how we would
build
Yelp okay so today we're going to be
talking about Yelp now just a warning
admittedly I'm pretty tired as I film
this thing so if I screw up don't lambas
me too hard in the comments going to do
my best to do a good one here so Yelp if
you are not too familiar with it maybe
you're operating in a country where Yelp
doesn't exist is pretty simple basically
it shows you a bunch of restaurants
around a given location that you can
pick and then once it does that you can
click a restaurant and see the reviews
on it so for example we've got a
McDonald's near me a Taco Bell near me
Jordan's juicy buns in upcoming chain
that uh has yet to open and Panda
Express and you can see the reviews out
of five on all of these guys if I were
to click one of them I could then see
what people actually went ahead and
wrote cool so let's actually go ahead
and formalize some problem requirements
so the first thing is that again if I
were to provide a location for now I'm
going to assume that would be lat long
you know maybe you could click that
somewhere on a Google map or you could
provide a zip code or something like
that we want to be able to find
restaurants within a given radius so you
know I go here and now I want everything
within a circle maybe this guy is 2
miles for a radius again once we click a
restaurant we want to be able to read
the reviews that others have posted on
it so that's easy enough and then the
biggest thing is that you also want to
be able to post your own reviews for a
restaurant obviously I have to tell
everyone how much I love Taco Bell it is
exactly why I am chunky right now okay
so again another big thing to realize
for this problem is because of the fact
that we are mostly reading reviews on
Yelp relative to the number that are
written basically we can prioritize the
read path and we can deprioritize the
right path now obviously it would be
great if we don't have to make that
decision but keep in mind that with most
of these problems these types of
tradeoffs do come up and we want to be
aware of
them okay so let's discuss some capacity
estimates so again these are going to be
pretty crude but I'm going to do my best
here so I looked up basically the number
of restaurants in the world and to the
best of my abilities it seems to be on
the scale or magnitude of around 10
million seems to be around 1 million for
the us so I think that checks out as
well and then let's imagine that there
are around 100 reviews per restaurant I
did look up on Yelp in particular how
many reviews they have and I think these
figures also are kind of in line I saw
around 20s something million so I think
it's reasonable to imagine we could have
100 million so again if each review is
around 1,000 characters long because
people people on Yelp just love to be so
very wordy that can be around 1,000
bytes and so if we multiply all of those
figures together maybe we have a
terabyte of raw review data now of
course that is going to be a floor right
we can have plenty of metadata here uh
plenty of other characters associated
with these reviews and so even though
there is only a terabyte of metadata I
imagine that in reality it's going to
take quite a bit more storage than that
to actually store all of these reviews
uh even still you know maybe we could
get away with one super large uh data
based node or something like that but in
reality we'll probably end up doing some
partitioning especially to fusure proof
this thing and I can't imagine that your
interviewer is going to let you get away
without talking about partitioning
anyway so we'll talk about it okay cool
so the first thing that we're actually
going to be talking about is reading
reviews the reason I want to talk about
this first is because I think it should
be relatively simple reviews are
effectively a credit operation you
submit them and then you go ahead and
read them back so basically the idea is
we're going to be reading reviews a lot
more frequently than the number of
reviews that are written so we want to
optimize for those read speeds we don't
really care that much about the right
speeds if I have to write a review and
it takes a couple seconds to submit no
big deal I probably submit one of those
like once a year okay so a quick
database schemo would be something like
the ID of the author uh the restaurant
ID uh the date of when I submitted it
the number of stars and also the content
itself in terms of replication obviously
we do want fall tolerance of our data
and again since we're not optimizing for
our right speeds I don't really feel the
need to do anything complex here I think
single leader replication will make sure
that we don't have to deal with any
sorts of right conflicts while also
ensuring that we can still get the read
speed boost of having multiple replicas
and of course our data will be fall
tolerant so we're going to go with
single leader here uh for partitioning
uh we can just go ahead and do a hash
range on the restaurant ID the reason
for this being that the one time we
actually access these reviews is per
restaurant so we want to make sure that
all the reviews for a given restaurant
are on the same node again because we're
assuming there are around 100 reviews
per restaurant it's really not going to
be the case that some of these
restaurants are so hot that uh you know
one partition in particular would be
overloaded I think if that were to be
the case we could always Rectify this
with the fact that you know perhaps we
could use some caching to help Shield
our database partition from some of
those reads I don't think there would be
a ton of Rights because at the end of
the day the number of rights to actually
review a restaurant is limited by the
number of people that restaurant can
seat and so again if there are a ton of
reads I think introducing a caching
layer will help us a lot here and we can
talk about that in a bit so if we are
just going to talk about a quick
database Choice again performance is
really not my main concern here I'm more
concerned with correctness and ease of
use and as a result I think just using
something like MySQL or any other type
of typical relational database is going
to be just fine for this particular
problem so go ahead and use my SQL let's
move on the next piece of this is going
to be finding restaurants now if you've
watched my systems Design Concepts
videos this piece of the problem is
something that you should be very
familiar with at this point I'm not
going to go too in depth to it however
what I am going to do is give a general
overview of how something like a
geospatial index works and if you want
some more information on that you can
watch the dedicated concept video so the
main idea is this right we're looking
for all the points near a certain X and
y-coordinate in reality it would be lat
long but X and Y is going to be a lot
easier for us to think about so the idea
right here is Imagine we've got this
point right this is me and I want to
find everything within this circle right
here that's exactly what we're looking
to do so if we were using a typical
database index recall that what we can
do is we can sort on one particular
column of that database table and if we
want to do anything better than that
well we can inner sort once we've
already done that sort so the issue here
is that these values are not discrete
right like we're not looking at 6.1 6.2
blah blah blah blah we're looking at uh
basically infinitesimally small
differences in terms of your X and
y-coordinate so basically the best thing
that we can do with our database is say
okay well first if we're looking from
the range of x from 6 to 8 first we have
to find all the points where X is
between 6 and 8 and then from there we
can find all the points where Y is
between 5 and 7
and so if we're using a typical database
index where we're first indexed on X
what this is going to do is first return
us all of these points where X is
between 6 and 8 and now you might think
to yourself oh well this is easy enough
if we do an inner index on the Y field
we're just going to be able to find the
perfect intersection that we want right
here and the fact of the matter is is
that's not true because keep in mind
that Y is only sorted per x value and if
all of these little points have slightly
different X values right this could be
uh 6.01 this could be 6.02 and on and on
and on then the internal sorting of Y
doesn't actually do us any good and what
we effectively end up doing is a
complete linear scan through all of
these
points and that's going to be
expensive cool so what can we do that is
actually going to be a little bit better
keep in mind that you know it doesn't
seem so bad when I draw out a small 2D
plan like this but in reality you know
this is like the entire oop switched off
my pencil the entire
length of the globe right you're taking
an x- range and then you're traversing
the entire circumference of the globe
that's how expensive we're talking that
can be a lot of
places so again what can we do better
what I'm now going to introduce is the
concept of the geospatial index now
there are actually a few different ways
of achieving our goal right here uh you
can do something something called uh a
geohash you can do something called a
quad tree or you can do something called
uh a Hilbert curve but the general idea
behind all three of those approaches
generally speaking is that you're
effectively trying to map out a 2d space
as if it were just one dimension and
I'll explain how we're doing that I'm
going to show off the geohash approach
in particular but at least the quad tree
approach is super similar okay so let's
imagine that we've got all of these
boxes right we take our world our 2D
plane of our world we divide it into a
bunch of different boxes and every
single box has a bunch of inner boxes so
let's imagine that I take the 2D plane
and I start by dividing it into four
boxes a b c and d the next thing that
I'm going to do is I'm going to take
every single box and in turn divide that
into four and what I'm going to do is
take all of those inner boxes keep the
prefix right so if we have box B over
here the inner box is going to start
with b and then I'm going to append a to
it for the top left and then I've got BB
and I've got BC and then I've got BD and
if I wanted to I could even break this
guy up even more and this would be b a a
b a b b a c b a d hopefully that makes
sense and so as you can see every single
box has one quarter of the area of its
bounding box and so if we keep going
through these boxes arbitrarily smaller
and smaller and smaller so that now I've
just got a little bit of a point over
there and I label that point with its
own very very small bounding box you
know that could be even a couple feet
big let's say I don't know the sixlet
box or
something is like 2 feet squared or
something the math is wrong it doesn't
really matter hopefully you get the
point if we were to take all of these
hashes right of the sixlet boxes and
imagine that you know we took every
single restaurant and mapped it to one
of these sixlet boxes
and then we actually sorted those in
alphabetical
order right hopefully you can see that
points that are actually close together
on disk are going to be close in both
the X and Y Dimension why is that well
let's take these two for example we've
got AB D ab and ab b d b d so AB D AB is
going to be
where let's see it's going to be in this
box so that's AB then we're going to do
ABD which is going to be in this box
right here and then it's going to be in
this box right here and basically uh
this other guy the second guy is going
to be in this box right here so because
they are alphabetically close to one
another in a 2d uh plane they're also
actually close to one another and so
that is going to help us a lot so
basically now we can actually go through
an example of finding a restaurant once
we have a geohash for it so if we know
basically the mapping of all of our
geohashes on our 2D plane which we have
because we basically establish that
mapping first and then we start putting
the restaurants on the map we can
basically quickly take a an XY
coordinate and figure out it's geohash
so in this example we have 1.8 comma
point5 so if we know that we have 1.8
comma point5 the first thing that we're
going to do is say all right 1.8 is
between 0 and two so that puts it over
in this box on the
left and 0. five is between 0 and two so
again yeah bottom left point is in the
Big C box then from there we continue to
basically go and figure out which box
we're in 1.8 is between 1 and two and
0.5 is between 0 and 1 so that's going
to put us in the CD box this guy over
here and then finally because we know
that 1.8 +3 because our radius is going
to be3 in this case is greater than 2.0
which is the bound the right bound of
CD right
bound of CD we will also need to check
for points in DC where DC is right here
so hopefully that gives you some general
idea of how we're actually going to find
uh the boxes that we need to search for
points right so this entire process of
figuring out um which geohash our Point
actually belongs in is O of log n
because every single time we are
basically logarithmically limiting the
search space that we care about in order
to find that geohash we're not linearly
scanning through every single box but
rather we're going from here then we're
going to here then if this were split in
four we would go to here hopefully that
makes sense uh basically it actually
becomes a pretty quick process because
even if your boxes are say 12 layers
deep uh that just means you only have to
do 12 traversals rather than going
through every single super small box and
checking every single one of them so now
the idea is this once we actually have
uh CD and DC as the two boxes that are
uh restaurants can be in all we have to
do is actually binary search our
database index in order to find all of
the other restaurants that are in those
boxes so the reason for
this is that if you recall if I have a
box right here I'll take a a anything
inside of it is also going to start with
AA and then the second that we get to AB
we're no longer inside that box so as
long as I take points in the range from
AA to AB I know that I'm within that
bounding box and the same thing is going
to apply here so if I want to find all
points in CD I just have to search for
all points from CD to Da and then the
same thing with DC to DD okay so
hopefully that should make sense uh even
though this is in theory uh a scan that
has to be linear you can actually speed
it up because our index is sorted and
you can do a binary search so that
search is actually going to be o of log
n as well so this is going to be
logarithmic relative to number of
restaurants and earlier we also talked
about being logarithmic but that was
actually uh
relative to number
number of bounding
boxes so it's getting a little messy
here but hopefully at this point you now
understand that if I erase a couple of
slides blah blah
blah so now what we've done is we've
effectively gone and said okay we have
all of these points right here the last
piece of the puzzle is to actually Loop
through every single one of these points
and check whether it's actually within 3
3 miles of our main point our original
restaurant if it is we keep it if it's
not we throw it out what's the math
equation we need for doing that well we
can just do the Pythagorean theorem uh
if you recall if I have a point right
here the distance between this point and
my restaurant is going to be the Y
difference the X difference let's call
this the D d^2 is equal to x^2 + y^2 and
then I just you know I take the square
root of d^2 to actually find in the
distance fantastic high school geometry
it is coming into play so hopefully we
can move on now and that mostly made
sense so from here we can actually start
talking about our actual restaurant data
choices the first thing that we need to
do is talk about our schema so of course
we're going to have a geohash of course
we're going to have a restaurant ID
we've got a name of the restaurant we've
got its S3 link if it has a photo uh we
have a certain number of reviews a total
amount of of stars and the reason I have
a number of reviews and a total amount
of stars is that generally speaking we
want to show the average here and so the
best way to compute an average if we're
uh gradually adding more reviews over
and over during time is we just keep
track of the total number of stars the
people have added as they submit reviews
and the total number of reviews and then
we can divide number of reviews uh or
rather divide the number of total Stars
by the number of reviews to get the
average and then of course just the raw
latitude and longitude we should have as
well so like I mentioned this guy is
going to net us average
stars and in addition we want our data
in our Geo index to avoid any
distributed joints right like in theory
I could have none of this
data in our Geo index and just only have
these two and then join on restaurant ID
but then that would take a little bit
longer because now all of a sudden I
have to go to the restaurant's database
and do an additional join so it would be
better if we denormalize our data a
little bit we can use something like
change data capture in order to do so so
uh again another aspect of this is that
number views and total
stars are a counter or rather an integer
that we plan on incrementing relatively
frequently now I will say because not
that many reviews are getting submitted
we probably don't really have to worry
about lost update race conditions where
you know we're incrementing this so
much we're incrementing we're
incrementing we're incrementing and some
of them get lost due to the actual race
condition and us not locking uh but even
still uh if we just want to keep this
data consistent with our reviews data we
could either a update it via a two-phase
commit which is going to be slow but we
don't really care because we don't care
that much about our right speeds when we
submit a review or B if we wanted to
whenever we submit a review uh we can
use change data capture uh use some sort
of stateful consumer like Flink uh to
make sure sure that every single message
will eventually get processed and then
go ahead and increment our number views
counter and our total scar uh total
Stars counter as far as a database
Choice goes for the actual Geo index
that we're going to use I would just
recommend not Reinventing the wheel a
lot of existing database Solutions
already allow supporting Geo indexes uh
could be elastic surge could be
postgress in theory you could even build
your own too just my one concern is this
piece of a logic right here with the
pythag GRE in theorem you're probably
going to have to figure out how to do
that in SQL uh just so that you don't
end up basically you know taking all
this data giving it back to your
application server and then doing the
filtering there because then you're
wasting Networth uh Network bandwidth uh
transferring all that data so hopefully
that makes sense another piece of this
puzzle like I started to mention earlier
is data caching so in both the case of
actually fetching locations as well as
fetching reviews uh it would be great if
we could go ahead and cash certain
popular queries the reason being that
certain restaurants a lot of people are
going to look up the reviews for uh for
example if you're from New York uh
perhaps you've heard of Carbone
particularly famous and uh I'm sure a
lot of people are looking at the reviews
of it because they think about going and
then they realize they can't get a
reservation so again it may be
beneficial for us to catch the popular
ones uh this would be uh for Jordan's
juicy buns a great restaurant or for
just in general restaurants near Time
Square that's a big tourist destination
so I'm sure a lot of people are looking
up this
query now of course uh the question is
what type of cash do we actually want
here well I think part of it depends on
whether we know in advance what type of
data is going to be popular and to an
extent we actually may right like
restaurants near Time Square we probably
do have an idea that Time Square is
always going to get a lot of traffic um
at the same time though I think it's
totally fine if we just have a cash Miss
we use an lru cache and then we pull in
the data as people request it and of
course if they're a popular queries
because the data is not never going to
be least recently used it'll stay in our
cache and so you know if this is a
popular
restaurant it would also stay in our
cash as a lot of people query for the
reviews of it cool so my last thing was
yeah potentially we could pre-populate
something like
this but it's really not that big of a
deal I think then there's another
question of well do we want to do a
right around cash do we want to do a
right back cash do we want to do a right
through cach like I mentioned just
because don't know in advance whether we
even want to cash a value I think that
uh right around is by far the most
feasible approach here uh but I can see
Arguments for otherwise honestly I'm not
sure that I even can see Arguments for
otherwise I think right around makes the
most sense in this case it is going to
ensure that our data is going to you
know use the database as the source of
Truth and unlike a right through cache
it is not going to impact our right
latencies okay so the last kind of piece
of this problem that is a little bit
complicated that we can go ahead and
talk about is going to be Geo sharded so
this always tends to come up with any of
these Geo index and it kind of results
from the following problem if you recall
basically all we want is that all of the
restaurants in similar areas are on the
same node the reason being that you know
if I'm going to query for all of the
restaurants near me I don't want to have
to hit five or six different partitions
to aggregate all of that data it would
be great if I could just hit one at the
same time it just so happens that you
know there are a ton of restaurants over
here in New York and there are very few
restaurants relatively speaking per
square meter over in Middle America and
so if I wanted to basically you know
evenly distribute these things uh per
square meter then I would run into
hotpots in terms of the way that my
partitioning is done so we probably
shouldn't do that so ideally what we
want is every single node is going to
have similar amounts of dat data in
terms of the number of restaurants and
what we'd also like is that every single
node is going to handle similar numbers
of queries and so of course these areas
are going to be hot spots this area is
going to be a cold spot if that's even a
term I don't think it is but I'm making
it up now we can use it from now on and
so the gist is well how are we going to
make sure that our load is balanced
across all of our
shards so basically the methodology that
I'm going to propose is as follows first
off we definitely want to be
partitioning by geohash range
the reason being that points that are
close to one another as geohashes are
close to one another in physical space
so if we randomly distributed our
geohashes over partitions again we would
have trouble getting good data locality
on our quaries but if we keep similar
geohashes together on the same nodes we
can make sure that we have that on the
other hand if we do keep all of our
similar geohashes together it is going
to be the case that certain very small
ranges of geohashes are going to have a
lot more data points for example New
York City is very small but that has
almost 130th of the restaurants in
America at the same time Middle America
is pretty big but that's going to have
very few restaurants so again we're
going to have to assign a smaller range
to one partition and a much bigger range
to a different partition but eventually
they'll probably actually get similar
amounts of load so we could do this uh
with Dynamic partitioning and that can
get pretty complicated in the sense that
you know if we're moving partitions
around as our servers are actually
running uh you know that can get complex
in terms of correctness uh if we were to
do that um we would probably have to
basically you know take a copy uh take a
partition we'd have to copy it to
another node if we were using fix size
partitions uh then we would have to
start replicating from one node to the
other that we're copying to and then
eventually we could take our load
balancer or zookeeper instance or
whatever and basically modify our
consistent hashing function to say that
instead of having our rights point to
the the old partition we would now have
them pointing to the new Partition so
that is definitely one option of
something that we can do uh I think this
is just a General Dynamic partitioning
question of whether we want to do it
during downtime or something like that
or should we stop any rights from
actually happening use a distributed
lock or something um I think there are
many different approaches of doing this
and all of them have their pros and cons
uh additionally just as far as the
actual calculation of which rows are
going to go on which node there are
actually a bunch of libraries in
particular
uh with geohashing that can compute load
for us assuming we give them our our
data in terms of uh which hashes are
getting access the most I think Google
in particular has one called
S2 okay so you know how would we want to
go ahead and partition our
balances how would we go ahead and
balance our partitions like I said I was
getting tired well if we graph out
basically the load per geohash or
geohash range the general idea is that
we want it to be the case that every
single partition is getting equal
amounts of load so imagine like this was
the range representing New York City and
you know this was the range representing
Middle
America and this guy is a little bit
more popular over here but it's still
not as popular as New York City in terms
of the number of queries so maybe this
is
Chicago and then over here this isn't
too popular at all so maybe I'll call
this like um you know uh Rocky Mountains
area and so the general idea is well you
know there's 100% load across this
entire curve ideally this would be 25%
this would be 25% this would be
25% and this would be 25% so we would
have to do some studying uh of load
metrics probably have a backend engineer
or performance engineer someone uh doing
uh an an analysis on that and then once
we actually come to that conclusion we
can go ahead and rebalance our
partitions accordingly I would imagine
for the most part that uh per region
uh these metrics aren't going to be
changing that much we just have to
record them one time and then get it
right from there
cool the last element of this problem is
going to actually be dealing with search
uh we are going to want to search
restaurants by name and this is going to
be pretty easy for us to do we've
covered search indexes enough in the
past we effectively just build an
inverted index where we would take a
search term like
McDonald's and then we would map it to
all of the different restaurants IDs
that are McDonald's number one number 20
number
45 and additionally the nice thing about
search indexes is they can account for
geolocation as well to do some amount of
scoring uh another good thing if there
are you know say 500 McDonald's
restaurants in the country which there
certainly are in this particular country
so again like I mentioned most search
indexes support some sort of Geo
indexing which is great unclear whether
we want to use it for our main Geo index
but uh we certainly could and then of
course the search index itself is an
inverted index we probably don't want to
be using this as our primary index for
restaurants because typically what we
want to do is get a restaurant by its ID
in order to edit it or change the data
for it or something like that and so a
search index which is inverted is not
going to be ideal for that so instead we
should probably just make it some
derived data which at least to me tends
to ring a bell in my head saying change
data capture and as you know I am a
Flink sexual and so we will show it off
in the next
slide great so the final aspect of this
puzzle is going to be showing off our
little Nifty design so of course if
we've got our client over here on the
left the first aspect of this is going
to be the right service if I'm a client
what can I be writing well the first
thing that I can write is reviews the
second thing that I can write to is
actually going to be the restaurants
table because you know perhaps I am a
manager of a restaurant and I need to
change the details of it if if we are
writing to the reviews table uh like I
mentioned let's keep it simple use my
SQL Shard on the restaurant ID and we
can actually take our change data and
put it into a stayful consumer like
spark streaming or Flink the one reason
I went with spark streaming here is
because in the hypothetical event where
you actually get so many different
reviews that you're constantly updating
this restaurant's table to reflect the
number of stars and number of reviews
for a restaurant spark streaming will
actually perform mini batching as
opposed to link which handles every
single event in real time and it still
has all the same guarantees as Flank In
terms of processing all messages once or
at least once and so as long as those
updates to the counter are item potent
uh you know we can always use like a a
last scene update key or something like
that to make sure that we dup our
updates there then we're good to use
spark streaming and so again that's just
going to increment the num stars and
also the num reviews use so that we can
uh quickly compute and average for a
given restaurant the same thing goes for
restaurants though the restaurants uh
table is also going to lead to some
change data capture so assuming we keep
this thing simple use my SQL Shard on id
id of restaurant in this case and sorry
I should have listed that this is my SQL
cuz again I don't really care about the
right latencies with the restaurants
table I just want to be able to read it
a decent amount and I just want to have
an easy to use interface the relational
data model is easy enough we're now
going to do some CDC into our kofka Q
which we need to use because it's a log
based message broker so it's actually
going to be compatible with
Flink which is going to be our next
staple consumer and this guy from here
is now going to make sure that a our Geo
index and also our inverted search index
both of which we can have uh in elastic
search are going to be kept up to date
from there the last element of things is
actually reading right we want to read
reviews we want to read nearby
restaurants and we also want to search
by
name and so these are the three things
that we can do and whether it is the
case that we're going to be reading
reviews or we're searching by name or
we're looking for restaurants near us
having an lru caching layer that is
basically just going to do this you know
we can implement this in
redus and basically having some nice uh
replicated caches uh you know just
making sure to take the most recent
result and keeping the popular results
is going to potentially speed up some
reads for us anyways guys I apologize
for being so tired and out of energy for
this video but hopefully it was still
informative as always I will see you in
the next one